anybody watching who's like oh man I bet
they're not even that hot it's fake or
it's just it's a plant that's how they
get the people to come on the show right
no no this is burning this is it hurts
hey what's going on everybody four first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by the fluffy guy
himself Gabriel Iglesias the hottest one
yes he's been a fixture in the stand-up
comedy game for 20 years strong a
producer actor and a man of a thousand
voices but how will he fare to dance
against the hot sauce devil we'll find
out today Gabriel welcome to the show
thank you how are you with hot food uh
you know what uh I like to taste the
food every now and then I feel uh feel
the need for a little spice well we have
the lifelines on deck to the left the
hot sauces to the right the walls are
caving in you're ready to get going I'm
ready to get going
[Music]
okay so this is a humble house uh-huh
I've seen in Tony I know that holds a
special place okay very much so - why
not let's do it
I don't want to say too much cuz I know
you guys gonna set me on fire later you
don't want to get cocked I don't want to
get contact I don't want to get caught
catches no I see the road right here
it's like when I used to run the mile on
hot back in school like yeah yeah uh-huh
uh-huh eventually we're gonna hit that
last leg okay so for the last few years
you've amassed an enormous collection of
Volkswagen buses close to 20 in total
telling fellow car enthusiast Jay Leno
this is what happens when you don't have
a coke problem why does the mini bus
hold such a special place in your heart
it holds a special place in my heart
because it was the first car I ever had
it was a 1968 Volkswagen Transporter bus
that my brother helped me get you know
it's one of those things it's your first
car and when I had the opportunity to
get my first car back one turned in a
two and then it turned into 25 the 68
transporter is that kind of a cool car
to have when you're in high school or is
it one of those cars that just pretty
much locks you into being a virgin
through graduation pretty much and then
have you ever had a road rage incident
behind the wheel of a minibus and do you
find that it undermines your point at
all that's one of those cars it's not
like driving a Ferrari
people you know or like they give you a
thumbs up and they're like wow cool
where'd you get that they want to talk
to you they don't call you a dick
whether you know I'm circling going to
Dunkin Donuts
okay so from San Antonio we're going to
Louisiana Louisiana okay when I watch
your show like you just see the wings
out here but you don't see no steam or
anything coming off them I want to let
everybody know the wings are a good
temperature and I was afraid of them
below it's freaking cold now they're
good thank you I appreciate that
no so on your show Fluffy's food
adventures you travel across the country
exploring some of the more indulgent
sides of American cuisine like how to
make bacon wrap bacon or crispy maple
chicken doughnuts of all the over the
top restaurants that you visited which
one was the most memorable oh that would
have to be this restaurant in North
Carolina
cowfish everything in there's ibrid so
they combine the best of both worlds and
I ate a thing called a beurre gooshie
which is basically a burger and sushi
combined which is pretty awesome
and then you've visited that place the
Heart Attack Grill oh yeah yes which is
an interesting place you know they'll
have you wear a hospital gown I think
they've had two spokespeople go down
with heart attacks the beauty of the
Heart Attack Grill is that they don't
hide anything if you're over 350 pounds
you get to eat for free but we get to
put you on display and make fun of you
in front of the whole crowd and you'd be
amazed how many people want to go up
there and be like
okay yeah I was got a little more
question sure mmm your fans give you a
hard time if you don't finish the wings
I think that most people are you talking
about the YouTube world that's what I'm
saying
that's I'm saying most people are
reasonable but then there are other
people that are like if you don't finish
the wings don't bother showing up and
they take it like very seriously and
they get really worked up I try not to
like play to them too much because I
feel like it's you know you give a mouse
a cookie you know I don't want to inch
it towards that direction you know just
turn this yeah
YouTube chicken wing challenge show but
to answer your question yes some of them
take it a little bit too seriously stop
taking it so freakin serious okay let's
have some fun with the show as someone
who's been the victim of multiple online
death hoaxes is that really as surreal
as it would seem to be the first time
someone said that I had died online it
looked legit because even had a news
like they did all the Photoshop things
right so it looked totally legit and I'm
not what it freaked me out and if people
started sending me text messages you
know hey go live yeah now that you know
the inner workings of a fake death have
you ever thought about masterminding
your own and to what end you know the
thought was there there came a point
where I just felt very overwhelmed with
everything that was happening around in
my life and my career where I was like
man I wish they'd just get away you know
the little there was a little fantasy of
like man oh it would be cool to fake my
own death but you know then you're an
[ __ ] when you come back you know what
I mean we thought you were dead and like
now we wish you really were I definitely
taste a difference from this one in the
last month but still in a manageable
place mm-hmm I know that fans they were
bringing you chocolate cake for so long
what's the next most popular item that
your fans gift you uh racist gift
baskets okay
I told the joke many years ago about a
friend of mine named G Reilly and how we
played this practical joke on him and we
made him a racist gift basket that Elkin
all kinds of stuff in it friggin fried
chicken watermelon you know malt liquor
I mean it was totally freakin like we
went off the deep end with it before I
knew if people started bringing me
Mexican racist gift baskets that had a
lot of hot sauce and candles of the
Virgin Mary my Saban is freaking Vicente
Fernandez CDs Mexican of us
one guy brought me at an application for
US citizenship the best one was a guy
gave me a lawnmower a straight-up lawn
mower and he's like yeah there's got
this right here for you man
like that's a nice lawn mower and then I
kept it and he got mad that I kept it
but I'm like you dude you gave it to me
what are you gonna do with a lawn mower
mm maybe cut grass I don't know what's
the most difficult thing about touring
with your chihuahuas ah whenever I got
to go to work I have to leave them in a
green room just like right now my dogs
are currently in the green room we're
hosting your dogs you're hosting my dogs
right now so thank you sorry for the
beep Pamuk Jang here we go I feel some
ham again I Gabriel so we have a
recruiting segment on their show called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our guests Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context sob bust
out the laptop I'll show you the
pictures and then you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good that
sounds good
first things first Stone Cold Steve
Austin
that was awesome I got to get drunk with
my favorite wrestler of all time and I
got to do his podcast and I didn't want
to show up empty-handed so I came in
with a couple bottles a bottle of Jack
and a bottle of tequila and some wussy
shot glasses that he didn't like and he
checked you in the shower checking on
the shot glasses before I know it we're
drinking out of his personal skull shot
glasses I manned up a little bit that
day and it was it was pretty awesome
this is interesting
Jay and Papa John yeah we take the nepo
sewed of Leno's Garage and he showed up
at the door with Papa John he had his
own like Papa John carts and so they're
like 10 $15 Pizza cards so like hey Matt
I don't well [ __ ] I here have a pizza
cart and I'll go just one cuz I saw the
stack he had I'm sorry you know I can
afford pizza but I'm still ghetto so
when I looked at the stack I'm like
maybe maybe like one more and it goes
here Amy and to me the whole stack of
Papa John cards
yeah so Thank You papa John what a day
alright karma sauce let's see here okay
come boy yeah Wow okay
I can I can officially say that now now
it's starting to really huh hmm no more
sandbox games it's you know real no good
no no no what do you remember about
performing and biker bars early on in
your career did you ever catch a bottle
in the middle of your set I used to
perform at a young nice to perform at
the shit's gonna hit the fan yeah
faizon perform at a biker bar and
Montebello called wile coyote I had no
idea that there was an element of danger
there I was 21 years old
and I was just happy to get on stage and
I'd make fun of anybody and everything
and the fact that these guys didn't kill
me said a lot because it was a couple of
shootouts there and it was a couple
people that actually died in the parking
lot or in the alley whatever you want to
call it the best part was I'm feeling
you know the best part is that across
the street there was a hospital the
Beverly Hospital so if you got banged up
you'd be an ER really quick very
convenient very convenient
[Music]
the Dawson's it doesn't sound very
threatening try a new Dawson's hotsauce
the premier yeah it's got the little
rope I guess it you hang yourself from
when you're done for you can set
yourself on fire sauce picante oh you
put spanner anytime you put Spanish in
the hot sauce it's it's legit yeah but
all the stuff on the backs in English we
get it alright here we go
so Dawson's hot sauce mm-hm so let me
guess
you've gone all the way every single
time right yeah I think I have to so it
comes to voice acting you're really in
verified air and we've experienced even
some of that today when is the last time
you used one of these voices in everyday
life oh man um Wow you're making it
harder to think probably a drive-thru
just to mess with them and then I would
always do that girl voice in freaking
out you know they're like ah cuz it
started off like a guy and then it ended
like a girl and then I get to the
drive-thru and then of course they see
that it's just me in the car
that's funny I feel I feel air leaving
like I ran out of breath on now
at what point am I allowed to drink
something listen there's no rules okay
but if you drink something are you
officially over did you lose there's no
it's not like there's not a competition
there's no money on this unless you want
to put some on it has anyone ever gone
through and not drink anything it has
happened a couple of times what does
that mean a couple of times what's never
happen on the show as far as the eating
of the wings you want to set a record of
some sort oh you know hey man you got me
out here and and I feel like I can
contribute something to this show and I
want to leave a lasting impression and I
just want to know what that is Dax
Shepard brought out an extra wing one
time on the last wing but no one's ever
brought out two extra wings on the last
wing well let's let's cross that bridge
when we get to it I still see three
wings and I'm still oh I'm a little too
brave right now all right you've already
eaten the bomb
[Music]
Wow Wow that that's that's really nice
really painful it's pretty obnoxious
yeah so throughout your career you've
boldly mixed aloha shirts and jean
shorts yeah i will not be that one who
does not drink you read one report that
you have what like 700 Hawaiian shirts
700 I think it's glue I think it's
closer to 50 now all you [ __ ]
uh yeah that's about 50 closer to 50
what do you think about high-end
designer
Hawaiian shirts like would you pay nine
hundred and twenty dollars for a Louis
Vuitton Hawaiian shirt never it would
not fit right I guarantee you're
Louboutin don't care about big people
what about couples wearing matching
Hawaiian shirts do you give that a pass
or does that make you want to puke
look a pencil hold air if you're in
Hawaii together I guess it's cute if
you're not in Hawaii fascinating stuff
can I just guess it's a straight anybody
watching who's like oh man I bet they're
not even that hot it's fake or is this
it's a plant that's how they get the
people to come on the show right no no
this is burning
this is business is it hurts Mad Dog 357
this is freaky it's got a bullet this
sauce is very hot that's all it says it
just repeats itself almost like don't do
it type of thing thing is at 24 25 year
anniversary has been setting people on
fire for 25 years real longevity in the
game hmm how you feeling I'm hurting I'm
hurting we got I see the finish line
though there it is warrior spirit hmm
so you spoken in the past about
finessing your way out of tickets be it
by playing the bad boys theme during a
traffic stop or by hooking up free
Krispy Kreme Doughnuts can you break
down the Gabriel Iglesias master class
for finagling your way out of a ticket
um the way I get out of tickets now
that's like a sign like George Lopez up
here okay I get our tickets hmm the way
the way I get out of tickets is nowadays
I'd probably been stopped four times in
the last two months each time they come
to the window I've gotten recognized and
it's like do you know what Hey and when
I hear Hey that means you're in the
clear means deuces I'm out hmm just a
politic situation totally I see one I
see one left
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
all right so the last dab how much did
you put right there all right and I
would like to point out to the viewer at
home this is textbook right here this is
pretty and perfect the last dab is I've
ever put on a wing so if you're ever
wondering what's a dab what's a dad
what's dad that's pretty good right
that's even better it's a good dab this
is a this is a real dream team allowance
type of last dab situation or a bro
cheers my man see you on the other side
see on the other side
ah
clearing the glass this hurts all right
Gabriel Iglesias here we are at the
finish line I know that you're a huge
wrestling fan
some might say an obsessive so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna put 30
seconds on the clock I have a bunch of
catchphrases from famous wrestlers I'll
hit you with them see how many you can
match to the wrestler does that sound
goodness that's good all right the best
there is the best there was the best
there ever will be Bret hitman Hart bang
bang
have a nice day mankind I'm straight
edge which means I'm better than you
CM Punk oh what a slobberknocker Junior
whoa Ric Flair hello ladies
Val Venis huh I'm a tower of power too
sweet to be sour I'm the tower of power
- I'm gonna sound like that for real all
right next one that's an order maggot
sorry slugger
give me a hell yeah hell yeah freakin
uncle now can you dig that sucker damn
it Booker T Booker T Booker T look at
you gabriel iglesias even with the last
dab the bomb Mad Dog coursing through
you still reaching in and naming some
catchphrases knocking down wings
cleaning bones so impressive from this
side of the table and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
or this camera let the people know what
you have going on in your life right now
Selleck right I got a lot going on in my
life right now I got my new tour it's
called one show fits all get your
tickets that fluffy guide.com
minute if I don't make it past this it
was fun
[Music]
oh yeah right there thank you dude you
do this every week I'm doing this
tomorrow Oh God your gangster bro hey
what's going on hot ones fans its Sean
Evans and you know what I'm not going to
beg for your subscription if you're not
subscribed turn off the video it's over
I want just my subscribers come here
come here if you're subscribed to first
we feast I just want to say thank you
and then I appreciate you that I love
you and I hope that you have a great day